today we are facing the greatest threat
to democracy and the rule of law on our
continent since before the Treaty of
London was signed
with Russia waging a war of aggression
on European soil and China growing in
assertiveness
the world is becoming more contested and
more volatile
the challenge to our values is growing
and the moment to push back is now
democracies like ours must build
resilience so that we can out cooperate
and out-compete those who drive
instability
that's why we're working so closely with
our friends across Europe
through the G7 NATO The Joint
expeditionary Force the European
political community and with a welcome
new tone in our relations with the
European Union
friends the United Kingdom may have left
the EU but we have not left Europe we
remain a proud European nation
and we must work together to defend the
values we all hold so dear
the Council of Europe with its huge
reach has such a vital role to play
and we need to think about how this
Council should react to the realities of
today
we showed great purpose in expelling
Russia last year acting decisively
together within days of the invasion
and let's bring that dynamism to the
issues before us now
and let's send a message from this Hall
loud and clear that we will stand by
Ukraine for as long as it takes
we will hold Russia accountable for the
horrendous war crimes that have been
committed
and we must also learn the lessons of
this war
by being prepared to confront threats to
our societies before they become too big
to deal with
that includes acting on cyber security
and AI
and it means tackling illegal migration
the moral case for Action is clear
we can't just sit back and watch as
criminal gangs profiteer on people's
misery
illegal migration exploits the most
vulnerable
it risks crowding out those with a
genuine case for Asylum
and it strains the trust that our
citizens have not just in our domestic
borders but in the International System
and that's why so many of us are already
acting at the national level
and why we need to do more to cooperate
across borders and across jurisdictions
to end illegal migration and stop the
boats